empieza la cuenta atrás para la cumbre
de la otan que se celebrará en la
capital española el 29 y 30 de junio y
el país última los preparativos madrid
se blindará con 10.000 agentes de las
fuerzas de seguridad del estado y
sistemas antiaéreos vigilarán el espacio
aéreo del país el que será el mayor
despliegue de la seguridad de la
historia de españa' pretende garantizar
así una cumbre sin contratiempos para
ello además se restablecen los controles
aduaneros en aeropuertos incluso para
vuelos desde países europeos para un
evento que cobra una nueva dimensión
este 24 de febrero cuando vladimir putin
invadió ucrania habrá presentes 5.000
participantes y delegaciones de los 30
miembros de la otan y de varios países
invitados como por ejemplo suecia y
finlandia que están tramitando su
ingreso a la alianza atlántica el
ministro de exteriores español confirmó
que el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
cell en sí participará a través de
videoconferencia en este evento que
incluirá temas como la ciberseguridad o
los usos de estrategias híbridas como lo
son por ejemplo los flujos de energía o
de personas migrantes como chantaje
a la seguridad de los países de la otan
también se pule en los detalles de una
contracumbre organizada los días previos
que finalizará en una manifestación
pacifista y anti otan este domingo en
madrid convocada por asociaciones que
piden una seguridad desmilitarizada y
que rechazan el aumento del gasto
militar que pide la alianza atlántica
además se manifiestan en contra del
costo que organizar esta cumbre supondrá
para españa que es un monto que aumenta
y que supera los 30 millones de euros